der Traum vom Eigenheim wird Ihnen
präsentiert von renovero für jedes
Projekt Handwerker einfach online finden
auf
renovero.ch sie ist
bereit also wir haben Glück dass wir in
des wunderschön
Hauf ist das H der 70er Jahre und H du
vorstell einiges machen oder Problem ist
W sind alle sehr sehr und darumag Stop
nicht
ma so groß wie Tennis das wurde gestern
Abend von einem Unwetter getroffen
wahnsinnig noch 5 mm dann ist
gut
[Musik]
Melanie und Markus hefliger Leben in
soloton zusammen mit der 7 Monate alten
Tochter Grace der Name erinnert an den
Ort wo die beiden geheiratet haben Maui
auf
Hawaii reisen ist eine Leidenschaft der
zwei genauso wie die Liebe zum Süden der
Schweiz und dort wollen sie nun ein
langersehntes Projekt realisieren wir
haben Glück dass wir im des
wunderschönes Hus hab kaufen also
eigentlich zwei h hab rustig dazu gehört
und sind jetzt am Plan das umzbauen
Renovieren ist das H der 70er Jahre und
kan du vorstellen einiges machen oder
ist super spannend Projekt was mit dem
bestehend machen und wo bringen oder das
ist macht das ganze sehr spannend die
Immobilie befindet sich im cento Valli
ein großzügiges Grundstück mit 5000
quadr Umschwung bis 2020 war das ein
sommerferienhaus neben der Villa und dem
kleinen Pool gehört auch ein rustiko zum
Ensemble das diente früher als
Ziegenstall hefligers planen eine sanfte
Renovation erwarten jedoch einen
mehrmonatigen Umbau sie haben lange
gespart um sich den Traum v eigenen Haus
im Süden zu
erfüllen viel geschafft durch dass me
Tochter haben wir vorher bei die
volollzit geschafft und haben unser so
Kapital für die Immobilie
[Musik]
wirrtschaftet Markus ist Ingenieur in
Chemie hat er als Berater für
Pharmaunternehmen
gearbeitet Melanie betreibt einen
Onlinehandel für
Kosmetikprodukte Design interessiert sie
seit
jeher darum wollen sie die Bauarbeiten
selbst
managen
alsojek kauft schon relativ klare
vorstell was man W ma designtechnisch
und von D
her ja wie W eigentlich was und jetzt
brauchen man einfach nur die geeignete
Handwerker W uns unterstützen noch
Challenge pun hab mehr halbe Million zu
verfig hat mal aufstell gemt SST du was
immer Budget also aktuell ja s B über
über de budg wir no verschiedene Punkt
wo wo wir optimieren der technische
Lösig und die guten guten
Mutes noch glauben die zwei fest daran
dass sie die nötigen Absprachen für den
Bau vorläufig aus der Ferne organisieren
können von solotor
[Musik]
aus wir machen sehr viel jetzt mit mit
den Handwerk
Skype und wenn es den effektiv in
baufase gut danke W den schon Vorort
also sprich paauwochen ferie
verbringen auf
baust
dar sch
[Musik]
nicht ein großer Tag hefligers sind
heute ins Tessin gereist um den Vertrag
mit der baunternehmung zu
unterzeichnen bitte nehmen Sie
Platz
machen wir haben die Chefin hier für die
Unterschrift
fantastisch sie schaut
genau wollen Sie später hier
leben das Wetter und das Klima wären ein
Argument dann die Landschaft die Täler
der See
ja französisch ist sehr hilflich vi vi
spreche Französisch zum
Englisch und Italienisch mit
Ferrari Französisch geinigt be
französisch sprechen und das
ist
se
schn italiis ganze mechen aber die ganze
Technik
vertragswe so das ist alles italienisch
und das Vokabular ist g gut
intus hast du alles ausgedruckt zeig mal
ja jetzt noch die Stempel nur mit der
Ruhe
okay sie ist
[Gelächter]
bereit war der längste Vertrag mit
Alptransit nein der mit Astra war noch
länger ein Vertrag so detailliert und
präzise dass er sogar erfahrene
baauunternehmer beeindruckt die bereits
Verträge mit Baustellen wie der Astra
oder Alptransit unterzeichnet
haben aber für hefligers ist Sicherheit
wichtig sie wissen beim Bauen ist
unerwartetes die Regel und nicht die
Ausnahme okay
[Gelächter]
einer für euch und einer für
uns jetzt Kön wir anfangen
[Gelächter]
endlich ist es soweit die Bauarbeiten
haben begonnen die Betreuung der
baustellet
starkastglich Vorort ist zum
Hauptansprechpartner für die Bauarbeiter
geworden ja zu Beginn me kan es von der
heimenus sin umsetzes Projekt und
irgendwie hab wirfach gemkt mit der
Diskussionen oder mit den Reise hin und
her es einfach schwierig ist finden wo
Problematiken oder Visionen verstt drum
ich nach entschlossen wirklich so der
heiße Phase vom Bau mögst viel oder
permanent F Vorort sie zum zum sicher
stellen und einfach ja mit
deriz darum haben sie in asona eine
kleine Wohnung
gemietet wie geht's alles in Ordnung es
geht
vorwärts wir machen
Fortschritte die Aussicht hier wird sehr
schön die Pflanze muss noch
weg gro rote Linie sind vorne sehr viel
fensterdück und viel l ien aber im
hinteren Bereich ist es nicht dunkel
aber nicht so viel l drum ma so so ja
doch relativ schöns
panoramafst den neuen Eigentümern ist es
wichtig den Stil des Hauses zu bewahren
das H so viel Charakter mit dem Holz mit
dem Stei mit der lag und das
ist sanft wenn verändern aber eigentlich
zum großen Teil erhalten will es ist ja
traumhaft schön für für uns ja das so
möglich auf Mod Stand bringen aber nicht
zu viel nicht komplett
ver
baustellenalbum m erinner bevor
[Musik]
fertig trotzs der Baustelle die Familie
nimmt sich Zeit für einen Abstecher ins
nahgelegene askona das Städtchen steht
ganz im Zeichen von Musik das jährliche
Jazz Festival hat eben
[Musik]
begonnen wir kenenus unser
Kindheit wir hab fer gemacht al beide
und ja Ken e relativ
gut die Stimmung ist gelöst und Grace
macht gerade neue
Freunde so eine
süße wollt ihr etwas mit uns
trinken versteht ihr
mich
ja willkmen das
gut
was uns vem gefallt einfach schöne
Wetter und halt die ganze so Italian da
was versprüt oder sind seh Kinder un W
Tochter und G un zentral unserem le
und hab
dasund also
lustig und
wir und
freundund hat
das und wer
konstant das wen
wirch
[Gelächter]
verbringen
spontan
[Musik]
Spangen
da ist ja die kleine genau die
kleine zeigst du ihr das
Haus wir schauen uns die Fortschritte
an machen wir eine kleine
[Musik]
Runde
cool richtig
schön
Knut vorstellen vi großzügiger
vor
g
schön
entsche ganz viel dann haben
hterzimmerf hier im Dachstock soll Grace
ihr Zimmer bekommen um mehr Raum zu
schaffen mussten Stützmauern Weg im
Moment trägt ein provisorischer Balken
das Dach dieser wird später durch eine
ausgeklügelte Konstruktion ersetzt an
der das Dach aufgehängt
wird wichtig dass es nicht
soch und das
istor
und das ist sehr dunkel g wir hab sehr
gestt s Platz zum Schl sie s Platz zum
Spiel wir hab gemacht dass man wirklich
viel l und
und G
rumfühl auch wenn die Arbeiten bisher
gut vorangehen die bauorganisation ist
aufwendig und
zeitraubend das alles neben dem
beruflichen und familiären
Verpflichtungen zu bewältigen zeht an
den
Kräften sch immer wieder
pausiert weil einfach ke
Energie so viel aber Traum ist schon
immer im Vordergrund gestanden und
uns machen uns einfach
vorgestellt schönes
Wochenende bis nächste Woche schönes
Wochenende
unser zweit Hus
rustier mus noch me in flieen aber wird
schön W machen mit V
[Musik]
traumhaft
Ortstermin in Losone Markus und Melanie
wollen heute die Steine für den Boden im
Erdgeschoss auswählen eine wichtige
Entscheidung die sorgfältig abgewogen
sein will zum Glück ist sich das Paar
meistens rasch
einig
V ler sie möchte gerne so
Mosaikform mit derpalten Oberfläche was
se typische
Oberfläche
wunderschön uns
vorstell das ganz
genau
das drüber diskutieren
machen schon fasziniert hab beide für
schöne für äthetische und wir haben uns
jetzt in
letrbildet ich sind sehr viel GIST vem
in den USA und viel in
unterw inspirier V den ganz verschiedene
Stil
[Musik]
in ihrem temporären zuause in askona
finden Sie Zeit im Fotoalbum der
Vorbesitzer zu blättern ich h Rück du
wie
sie Baustelle zuofort gemacht genau
dieich wie mir jetzt noch gröer das wir
jetzt gemacht das ist
schonück
[Musik]
mit weniger weniger gerade aber das zum
abtransportieren da wir noch der Wald
jetzt
geht
wenig das
verarkauft das direkt er Hand übernah
und wüss W es gehört
und also für mich schon wichtig zu
wissen vor gewohnt was für eine Geist e
Hus und das hat man aber auchemkt W h in
das ist ein gut g Energie g Energie und
uns das bestätigt wo wir den Besitzer
persönlich kennengelernt
haben
[Musik]
wir das heißt natürlich Doppel die mie
aber große span gemacht jetztade mit der
fanster da Amfang
Holzfenster spezielle Zone genau und
dann hab ich zu W ich das doch noch
richtig abär weil J Holzfenster sind die
dürstefenster wir haben für Holzfenster
das angeb 120000 und dann haben wir
schon mal schlucken weil das ist das ist
viel Geld eig Telefon gemacht und
Baubehörde und die haben denag ja ne gut
e gar nicht V der Straß a es spielt
eigentch keine Rolle was die für
fensterin machen hab uns B and entsch
und sind jetzt Glück dass der Hälfte
sind
von von dem ursprüngliche Betrag
[Musik]
endlich ist es soweit das Dach wird mit
Hilfe einer Stahlkonstruktion die
normalerweise für Hängebrücken verwendet
wird
aufgehängt so ist das Gewicht des Daches
auf die Außenwände verteilt das ist
nötig weil die tragende Mauer entfernt
wurde jetzt können wir anfangen die
Struktur zu
montieren
[Musik]
leg du den Meter hierhin ich
kontrolliere die Höhe des
[Musik]
Trägers ja ich sehe es
79,4 wir schauen dann nachdem wir es
gespannt haben
gut dann fangen wir jetzt
an ein
paar das hier ist das zentrale
Element jetzt noch die
verankerungselemente
montieren wenn alles befestigt ist ist
es als ob der Träger so hoch wäre
c0m
resen in alte von hier bis dort etwa 70
cm wir gewinnen ziemlich an Höhe der
Raum unter dem Dach wird viel
größer das hier ist schon
außergewöhnlich und wir mussten eine
Weile darüber nachdenken vielleicht
können wir es erneut anwenden wenn Herr
heliger wieder eine Konstruktion machen
möchter
queste Barre son Bar
acciilenus Stahl trägt eine Last von
5000 kg sobald das System aktiviert
ist poi anche in mezzo
[Musik]
me
okayens den Stahlseilen die das Tragen
haben wir quasi eine Golden Gate Bridge
das haben wir gemessen um die Struktur
zu kontrollieren und Andrea hat die Zahl
dann auf den Balken geschrieben genau
das lassen wir da das ist
Erinnerig gavo genau
eine
kleine wir machen eine kleine Plakette
Caro wir schreiben hier hat er
unterschrieben genau im Namen des Herrn
1000 irgendwas das ist nicht
schlecht ist es leicht
gespannt ja wir ziehen es 5
mm d die Stangen verschraubt sind können
die Stützen die das Dach tragen entfernt
werden noch 5 mm dann ist
gut jetzt hat es sich schon um 3 mm
gehoben
[Gelächter]
Spannung per
esktioniert wir haben kein Champagne
aber wir können ein Foto
machen ein Foto von uns unter de
Balken Moment
[Musik]
offiziell Lächeln
bitte mit den stahseile wo das
trage drüber Golden Gate ir Sinnbild für
die für die stahseile und
diekonstruktion und Techniker
her sch schön r
[Musik]
füremt die Dachkonstruktion
hältit
Spannung der 46-Jährige möchte
herausfinden wer sich auf seinem
Grundstück tummelt wenn die Bauarbeiter
Feierabend
[Musik]
haben natürlich schön wenn das Paar vor
den nachtlich Besucher kte auf Kamera
Ban Spur gesehen aber denke es könnte
wild Wildschwein sie und Dach ich Gag
mit Mario seid W cool wenn man die mal
auf Kamera könnte könnte se was Nacht
machen und
üb Grundstück
husche
sie dasar ke
schlech g ist
besserort finde wo fest machen nicht so
gut zum
[Musik]
befestigen wieder
Arbeit freizit Beschäftigung mitkameras
aufstellen
und was was
laäuft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wasprecheadiale heute bis zum 16 August
sind die tradell
zwei Wochen dauert die obligatorische
Sommerpause auf allen Baustellen im
feragosto heißt das hier etwas das man
in der Deutschschweiz so nicht kennt
feragosto Zwangspause
geseh W ger wi machen und sind so viele
Sachen in Gang und jetzt plötzlich alles
auf Null gestellt
ins maach dass ein Teil von den Arbeit K
machen will fir
es tut mir leid jetzt zu machen es ist
das erste Mal dass mir das passiert ich
sehe die ganze Arbeit was es noch alles
zu tun gibt wenn wir zurückkommen müssen
wir alles neu planen
mühsam so ist es
halt danke für alles schöne Ferien und
gute
Erholung
Schotten dicht
Baustelle
pausiert Rasa ist ein kleines schmuckes
Dorf im Centovalli das einzige imessin
das keine Straße hat das Dorf ist nur
mit der Seilbahn oder in einer guten
Stunde Fu Marsch zu erreichen ein
beliebtes
[Musik]
Ausflugsziel für mich und klar dass
später Kinder möcht sind vi wir hab uns
verwirklich
und Privileg dass man voll und ganz für
unsere toch und
wirklich ohne irgendwelche finanzielle
Sorge oder ja berfliche Sorge oder
[Applaus]
anderes für die 43jährige und ihren Mann
ist die Familienplanung noch nicht
abgeschlossen vielleicht kommt für Grace
noch ein Geschwisterchen
dazu
[Musik]
do ein Natur und nicht vi am Projekt
studier SP
wirlich
[Musik]
die
sch mit der Kamera s
gpannt
sind
[Musik]
ich glaub das kan
sogar mit
den
Säule
[Applaus]
schön poter
genau re die
photoshowau so viel so viel
die Familie scheint ihr kleines Paradies
gefunden zu haben mitten im Grünen
unweit vom
[Musik]
See Unwetter getroffen Menschen wurden
verletzt Autos zerstört Fenster
zerschlagen und die Schulen in Losone
schwer
beschädigt der heftige Sturm richtete
Schäden in Höhe von mehreren Z Millionen
Franken an
heftigers kamen mit einem blauen Auge
davon keine
Hagelschäden aber der starke Regen
flutete auch ihr Haus da es in Hanglage
steht haben Regenfälle noch eine
dramatischere
auswirkungus
unwter
verurst
Wasser wahnsinnig die
wasserm nur V der Flche das sch L das
langt ja ja das ist wahnsinnig
das mit dem befreundeten Ingenieur
begutachtet Markus das
Abwassersystem die Regenfälle haben sich
in den letzten Jahren verstärkt immer
öfter fallen die Mengen extrem aus und
überfordern das bisherige
System neu soll das Wasser seitlich dem
Haus entlang abgeleitet
werdeninageschicht und und dann vom Haus
weg in die neue Leitung die wir
darüberüberziehen und auch das Wasser
vom Dach
weil hier kommt richtig das viel hier
kommt richtig viel Wasser also das ist
wir haben gesehen als wir Laub
weggenommen haben hab 15 R genommen um
um das wegzukriegen das ist schon viel
Arbeit nicht musst musst es nicht und
das ist schön aber das ist besser und
vorher oft kommt oft das ist nicht
vorher gesehen aber du ja wie gesagt
lieber jetzt richtig als lange mit
ween das Wasser so eine Problematik fürs
die darstellen nicht nicht inchnen kann
das ist natürlich jetzt herusforderung
für fürs Budget zum das um bringen um
das ganze
System damit in Zukunft eigentlich
wirklich gut gut und optimal vom Wasser
geschützt ist die Drainage verursacht
mehr Kosten von mehreren 1000 Franken
zum Glück haben sie einen Budgetposten
Unvorhergesehenes gemacht nicht n ur das
Haus auch das rusti möchten hefligers
restaurieren sie wollen eine
Ferienwohnung
einrichten fertig unds rusti Schleider
immer noch nicht das H ein Grund und
zwar warten wir immer noch
baubewiähigungen die gich wie damals mit
dem Hus aber ist halt einfach so beim
Rus h du sehr viel auflag noch mehr beim
Hus
und Z A4 S mit
Auflagen wir haben jetzt rlag dass wir
nur das steidach machen wir
hab zeldach machen zeldach ist definitiv
günstiger aber das ist ganz klar ne vom
Kanton dass wir steidach m machen und
doch sowieso
reparierenfah dass es stürzt und wenn
jetzt stürz D nicht
Wegum und das auf jed Fall verhinder das
war zum sch Russ zum ander würde ich von
stand steibberg se das finde ich nicht
so toll und ja wir möchte es halt da
bewohnbar
[Musik]
machen das Ehepaar beschäftigte sich
eingehend mit dem Design der Möbel und
Küche in askona fanden sie eine
Schreinerei die ihre Wünsche umsetzt mit
unsere prechen mit dem Roberto l
Material h Materialmuster da ja sind wir
mal
gespannt
also da der Kühlschrank
oder da Platz gerade 20 cm für eine
kleine
Schrank das
ich mus gemacht für die da Ziel ist
eigentlich dass ich wi so machen
vielleicht was muss ich sagen vielleicht
wird der nicht genau 60 se aber
vielleicht mehr aber ich das kann ich
wir jede fronte so abschließen was uns
wichtig ist d man die Runde Ecke möchte
haben Kochinsel mit runden Ecke und
haben Badmöbel mit runden Ecke das zieht
sich so im ganz Hus dur das ist
Challenge jetzt mit mit dem Material W
da
sehen
das
[Musik]
schöntin zu der James W fir vor allem
Architektur und ja vi durch die Filme e
inspirieren Steib
sicher in Möbel wieder Aufgen im
Geheimdienst ihr majestä ist der auf
Schild spielt und habcht D das
tre und und das hat uns eigentlich auch
inspiriert für unser Hus dass man
eigentlich das WTE
sehrlichestalte eigentlich müssten die
Arbeiter jetzt weiter Steinplatten
verlegen aber stattdessen reinigen Sie
den Boden Stillstand auf der Baustelle
Problem ist Steib wurde sind alle sehr
sehr W plat
Leck natürlich V Muster ganz B anders
sprlich und darag sto so so nicht wi
machen jetzt mit dem Lieferant l wieso
jetzt die steichin sind das das
ursprünglich diskutiert worden ist und
PL und müsame Diskussion g aber jetzt
hoff dass die n W die ste der Größe
be die
liverger weiteren Arbeiten verschieben
sich ebenfalls um beinah D
Wochen die Renovation des Hauses dauert
nun bereits fast 5
Monate gleich lang wie die Vorbesitzer
für den Bau der ganzen Villa gebraucht
haben langsam macht sich
[Musik]
ungeduldbreit ist sich das ist gut und
sind fr jetzt in der sehr kleine woh und
jetzt langsam mehr DIN jetzt freuen wir
uns natür schon wenn wir Hus könt wo man
mehr Platz h und mehr
[Musik]
Komfor Mitte November ist es dann soweit
die hefligers stehen kurz vor dem Einzug
die meisten Arbeiten sind
abgeschlossenow ich noch gar nicht
gesehen ja da ist einiges ist
wunderschön hol wir
genial
abgund holstruktur her echt
schön natürlich
Highlight wohnzmer das schön
W
baustell nicht so richtig griffbar und
jetzt ist es jetzt s kurz vor vor wir es
wir
Resultat macht schon macht extrem fre
eine intensive Zeit liegt hinter ihnen
eine Zeit die Sie auch als Paar
verändert hat ist es braucht Energie es
braucht
aber wenn man es gut Team ist dann dann
schafft man das und ich danke
no gemacht ja
ja aus den ehemals engen Räumlichkeiten
sind offene Licht durchf Räume
[Musik]
entstanden und die dunkelbraunen Möbel
wurden durch helle
ersetzt besonderer Hingucker das
freischwebende
[Musik]
schm super schön
Worte genauso haben die hefligers sich
Ihr Traumhaus
vorgestellt
während des Umbaus ist auch eine neue
berufliche Vision
gereift das wer auch in Zukunft für
andere machen D einfach so ja schöne
Objekt Wied neues Leben oder dass man
unterstütze beim innenusbau beim Design
beim Umbau zum so Sachen zu realisieren
wo man
[Musik]
schön
das ist super gut Gefühl so wir wor oder
wird
vorestellt
glüsfühl
[Musik]
schönoh
sieer Spezialisten ihr Glück im Süden
haben die hefligers auf jeden Fall
[Musik]
gefunden der Traum vom Eigenheim wurde
Ihnen präsentiert von renovero für jedes
Projekt Handwerker einfach online finden
auf
renovero.ch